senators will start questioning Supreme
Court nominee judge Brett Kavanaugh this
morning in day two of his confirmation
hearing the first day started with more
than an hour of arguments between
Judiciary Committee Republicans and
Democrats each committee member today
will question Cavanaugh for 30 minutes
so today's meeting is likely to run well
into the evening Jan Crawford is going
to be there all evening Jan good morning
good morning guys so yesterday I mean
the battle lines were drawn early the
Democrats said they didn't even have
enough information to have a hearing
Republicans said that is ridiculous
you've got half a million pages of
documents on Breck have it on more than
any other nominee so right away you
could see those divisions and the main
themes became clear they're gonna be
sparked a lot of heat hopefully some
light as well
Democrats vowed to keep up the pressure
today when Judge Brett Kavanaugh faces
his first round of questions I think it
was completely appropriate that
Democratic senators chose to raise their
concerns Committee Chairman Chuck
Grassley noted that few if any of those
concerns focused on Cavanaugh's record
nobody has found any qualification
problems with this particular nominee
it's all been on process mr. chairman
I'd like to be recognized to ask a
question before we proceed the
interactions were part of a coordinated
strategy by Democrats urged Grassley to
postpone Cavanaugh's confirmation
Chairman I move to adjourn directly
joined by vocal public protests
Democrats press for the release of all
documents from Cavanaugh's time in the
George W Bush White House what are we
hiding they also pointed to the man who
nominated him we also find ourselves
with a president who faces his own
serious problems we have to confront an
uncomfortable but important question
about whether President Trump may have
selected you judge Kavanagh with an eye
towards protecting himself with his
family seated behind him Cavanaugh used
his opening remarks to lay out his
judicial philosophy a judge must be
independent and must interpret the law
not make the law and pledge to be
impartial and independent I do not
decide cases based on personal or policy
preferences I am a pro law judge now 70
protesters were arrested yesterday and
this disruptions will probably continue
today as Judge Cavanaugh goes in this
hot seat to face questions directly from
the senators John all right Jen thank
you